das ist ja etwas was ich an philipp so
spannend finde dass er immer wieder
gegen gewisse klischees die er
verkörpert sofort verstößt jetzt möchte
ich gerne auch von den besser kann
dieser clip nicht mehr und hat ein buch
gelesen ja endlich das buch heißt die
vereinigung der welt und das ist von
einem religionswissenschaftler namens
thomas bauer geschrieben es geht um die
zunehmend geringer werden bereitschaft
unserer zeit zweideutigkeit wahrheit
oder mit dem fremdwort ambiguität zu
ertragen also ich finde das sehr sehr
interessant etwas was man überall
tatsächlich in den sachbüchern findet
beim wilhelm schmid und bei harald
welzer usw
einfach dieses umkreisen von der
entwicklung dass die menschen offenbar
schwer doppeldeutigkeiten aushalten
können dass sie einfach was geboten
bekommen müssen was eindeutig ist ich
finde was thomas bauer macht ist ein
weiterer interessanter schritt er sagt
eben das hängt zusammen auch diese
unfähigkeit zum austausch mit einer
besessenheit unserer zeit mit
authentizität
die vorstellung dass man einen wahren
wesens kern hat den man unbedingt
erstmal entdecken und dann fliegen muss
ist das genaue gegenteil von jeder form
vom ambiguität es ist auch wie bauer
zurecht sagt das gegenteil von kultur
niemals sind die leute eigentlich so bei
sich also authentisch wie zum beispiel
wenn sie hats ab sondern ambiguität ist
einfach schluss endlich das was das
leben interessant macht ambiguität ist
auch das was literatur interessant macht
die natur die sich mit schillernden
gestalten beschäftigt mit gestalten die
in den grauzonen sich befinden und will
noch nicht märchen eindeutig gut
eindeutig schlecht sondern die ganz
viele verschiedene facetten haben und
eben nicht gleich in eine schublade
passt mir machen ja bei den
literaturclub da bleiben wir uns ja im
aushalten von mehr deutlich dass sogar
super dass du das erwähnst weil kunst
und literatur sind eigentlich ein feld
wo ambiguität florieren sollte literatur
fördert einen haben wir die naspa
theoretisch kompetenz sich genau
komplexen sachverhalten
auseinandersetzen und sie zu ertragen
das ist etwas was ich meinen kindern
immer mit gebe das musst du jetzt
aushalten das ist unauflöslich ist das
ist
furchtbarer frustration im leben eines
einzelnen ist das schlimmste was einem
widerfahren kann aber so ist es halt
[Musik]